hi everyone welcome to the khan academy
daily homeroom sal khan here
thanks for joining us we have a a pretty
exciting show i guess today for those of
you all that this is the first time
you're joining the whole idea is in this
time of school closures uh we at khan
academy we're trying to make sure that
you have the resources need to keep
learning that you know how to use those
resources
and that we have ways to stay connected
in times of these closures and that's
why we're doing these webinars and what
we're doing these live streams i do want
to highlight as i always do in the
seminar in these live streams khan
academy is a not-for-profit with the
mission of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and we
were running in a little bit of a
deficit even before
this whole crisis struck but now we're
seeing our traffic is 3x of what it
normally is and so any support is super
valuable i want to give a special thanks
to several corporations that have
stepped up in the last few weeks in
record time bank of america followed by
att google.org and novartis and many of
you have also helped donate to help
close our gap and we
and i encourage everyone whether you're
watching on
youtube or facebook or any other
platform post questions on the message
boards we have team members who will
surface questions and i can ask bill
those questions over the course of our
conversation
so bill great to see you uh maybe a good
place to start is
how is
the the situation affecting you
personally how's the social distancing
and where are you spending most of your
time
well i think uh everyone's lives are
almost completely upended you know the
normal
things i do you know talking about polio
eradication
going into meetings at the foundation
traveling to meet with scientists that's
all gone you know when i wake up in the
morning and i think was this a nightmare
or are we really in this almost
different world
uh where you know coronavirus is the top
priority we've got to get this thing
under control
i'm doing lots of online meetings i use
microsoft teams for those things i don't
get to see
many people beyond my
family
in person
so it's a you know huge adjustment and
um
you know yet there's so there's so much
to be done
uh it's not like i'm not not busy
and then where are you spending most of
your time is it around uh the virus work
yes that's
you know the
our foundation
uh works on infectious diseases we're
the biggest funder of uh vaccine work we
understand you know how to make vaccines
in volume we do the disease modeling and
so
uh the skill set we have understanding
private sector being able to work with
governments you know what regulatory
things should be maintained for safety
and but which ones because we've got to
move so fast
should you go around
you know and talking to leaders talking
to tony fauci about okay how do we make
sure the public is seeing this in the
right way
we explain why it takes so long for a
vaccine which is such a key thing to
uh you know until we have that
we can open up a bit but we won't go
back completely to normal
and so we're orchestrating
all of our partners around
uh getting the testing right
getting the drugs right
and getting a vaccine uh which
will will bring us to the end of this
yeah no we're going to talk more about
that and actually the first question i
want to surface is from facebook abid
sheikh and i think it's it's front of
mind for a lot of us he writes hello
since you predicted about a similar
outbreak in the 2015 ted talk how did
you react to the news about the kovid 19
pandemic and that he's referring to
famously for anyone who doesn't know
bill made a talk in 2015 that
essentially was very prescient of the
situation we're in now
yeah and i wrote a new england journal
of medicine article that really went
through the specific things like
high-speed diagnostics and uh
vaccine platforms that we needed to fund
you know this is certainly a case where
being able to say i told you so is not
at all gratifying because this is a
horrific disaster and in my lifetime
whether it's health or economics or just
uncertainty for people there's nothing
like this
uh and
the goal there was to get governments to
step up uh you know so that you could
easily make a new rna vaccine or you'd
have you know the testing capacity
very very rapidly
i'm sure
uh that because this is so widespread
that you know next time we will have
made those investments but it's it's
it's unfortunate that very little got
done you know our foundation welcome
trust a few others did fund uh work
along these lines uh but not enough
uh and you know so here here we are
and and give us a sense of where we are
right now and we could talk a little bit
about maybe what could have should have
happened but where are we now what's
your analysis
how bad is the situation in the u.s rest
of world how close are we to peak how's
it going to play out over the next few
weeks or months
yeah so
the concept of exponential growth is not
that intuitive to people but
when you have this human human
transmissible respiratory virus
it creates exponential growth that is
each case leads to
say two or more cases
and so that if we hadn't changed our
behavior
there's no doubt the majority of people
would be infected and you'd get this
huge overload of the medical system
and you know literally
millions of deaths
the reaction whenever you're going to
stop something that's exponential the
sooner you act the better because then
you can act in a way that you don't
overload your
hospital systems and you can treat the
cases very very well
testing is key to know where is the
spread and to inform people that
they need to really isolate themselves
the test the pcr test can actually see
the virus before you're symptomatic
before you would be transmitting to
people and so if we were had the testing
right prioritized that would help with
this
you know we
the social isolation
uh
by the end of the month with any luck
we'll start to see
uh the curve level off
and then another month the number of
cases would come down
and you could get to a point where
because you're targeting
the testing and giving quick results uh
that you do start to open up
in a way like china has where kids do go
to school people go back to their jobs
it's not normal that that is they don't
do sports events or big gatherings uh
that will wait until the vaccine but you
know we we'd like if things go well and
the numbers will drive it we'd like to
see that ability to open up somewhat uh
by uh ideally early summer
and are you all seeing evidence that the
social distancing is working that we are
on track to peak in the next few weeks
and then i get to maybe a an in a more a
better state by the end of i guess it
would be by the end of may
well china had in hubei province
uh over 80 000 cases and you know so
that's the model where they intervened
in a very dramatic way uh they enforced
their quarantine uh very strongly they
did their contact tracing they used the
testing people would get testing results
very quickly and it was the right people
they are now
able to open up south korea had a
reasonable number of cases
uh but they
did the testing did the tracing and so
now they
are in in the situation where uh they
they've definitely bent the curve there
are a few countries like taiwan who did
all the right things and never
allowed the large numbers to develop
that unfortunately for most countries uh
you know we we can't go back and change
the fact we missed that early
opportunity but they
you know there are communities where we
are starting to see the numbers peak uh
because of that social isolation so
that's the first step is that peak but
you don't open up until they're in
absolute uh way below like a factor of
five below where they are today
wow and just from us i don't know from
either economic or scientific point of
view
why do we see this disparity in testing
or even the types of tests in the u.s
right now even if you're kind of lucky
enough to get a test so to speak it
could still take several days to get a
result while you know i heard stories in
taiwan three months ago you get your
results before you leave the airport
yeah the very sensitive test is the
polymerase chain reaction pcr
where you make the primer specifically
for this virus it's an amazing test and
there's a lot of machines out there in
commercial labs academic centers public
health labs
that
we were slow
to get them all going even today we're
not
completely taking advantage of that if
you make sure you're testing healthcare
workers you don't let the cue get very
long
you're testing contacts and people who
test positive that really is guiding
individual behavior and the broad
behavior and so that in the us we
actually have more of those machines per
capita than south korea or anyone else
so
uh
it should be possible there isn't a set
of criteria though that stops somebody
who's not symptomatic from say
getting in the queue and testing
themselves every day just because
they're worried versus that health care
worker and so
we do need to bring a sense of
prioritization and not let these cues uh
mean that it's taking too long to get
the results back
are you hopeful that that's going to
change over the next couple of weeks yes
well there's a lot of discussion about
it uh you know the notion of okay
does the federal level really jump into
that which agency
uh
has the right expertise to be able to do
that uh
you know and and so
that i think is likely to improve in the
weeks ahead
and your prediction of hitting a peak in
the country in a few weeks one question
i've been curious about is you know
places like california i know in seattle
and washington
we've been in some form of a
stay-at-home policy stay-in-place policy
lockdown policy for about three weeks
now and you know the quarantine time is
typically two weeks why aren't we seeing
the peak cases sooner why is it taking
so much time
well
there's the leg of uh
you know once you do the shutdown you
need to go
you know at least uh maybe two infection
periods before you'd really expect to
see things going down also we weren't
doing enough testing uh and so you you
know now we're seeing
a higher percentage of what's actually
out there
uh
and but that the actual the numbers for
california and washington are very
hopeful you know the new york numbers
continue to go up we have cities with
explosive growth uh like detroit new
orleans
but the the there are early signs
uh
that
were we are our changes have made a
difference our lockdown is not as
extreme as what they did in china but it
should be enough
uh in the places where there's strong
adherence uh to to get to that peak and
so i'd say we'll see in some locales
in the next few weeks we'll see that but
for the country
uh at best it would be the end of the
month
and what's your sense of why new york
has had such a tough situation
you know they're in a lockdown situation
now is it just the nature of the density
of people or is there something else
going on there
well the international travel
into new york is more than anywhere else
the density is more
than anywhere else uh and you know these
things
you know there's some degree of bad luck
when you're dealing with exponentials
you know just a few cases here at the
front of the exponential can drive a big
separation between
place a and place b
and uh you know the governor there is
stepping up uh
and
you know getting the modelers to help
him understand what's going on uh
enforcing their lockdown in a in a
pretty serious way
uh you know so hopefully you know the
deaths uh
are another legging indicator because
those are you know people who are
infected 18 to 20 days earlier but
uh
you know we really hope that new york
peaks because they are
uh near the breaking point for their
medical system
wow and you know you're one of the
world's experts and you've worked with
many of the world's experts on things
like vaccines obviously there's a lot of
talk about a vaccine i have a question
here from facebook siam kumar asks
he's calling you billy that's a little
informal
any insight into how long this vaccine
will take time to come to market and
actually i'll add a second question to
siam's question you know how long and
also how effective will it be i know the
the influenza vaccine is famously not
100 effective and it depends from year
to
year that is uh super important here we
only have one strain of the coronavirus
uh so we don't have the same shifting we
see in flu so that makes it an easier
target
the foundation works with the
uh you know greatest funder of vaccine
work so
of the 100 or so efforts out there
uh there are about four that use a new
approach dna rna which they're getting
that going if that works if it's safe
and efficacious including an old people
which is super important here those will
be done uh the first then we have four
others that are more conventional
techniques but the risk of them not
working is lower so we we're funding
the manufacturing capacity and the
safety and efficacy of all eight of
these very much at full speed because
governments in a few months their money
will really start to flow but they're a
little bit slower and they don't really
understand which of these organizations
uh have which capabilities you know you
saw the moderna which is an rna vaccine
actually going to phase one safety
trials
last month so they were the first to get
to that milestone
we need to back
all the eight leading candidates because
you know some
uh won't be safe some won't be effective
we're saying to people it's likely about
18 months because of the scale issues in
the best case yes things could be done
before then in the worst case it would
take longer this is super important
because until we have
uh an applications vaccine that the
entire world
has had the benefit of
we will not go completely back to normal
that is large gatherings
even if we've kept the cases under
control schools are open people are
going back to their jobs the large
gatherings the risk benefit ratio
could is not strong enough because you
could get a super spreading and a bit of
a rebound there
and you know so people will be fearful
people won't be
behaving like they were
before this and so
you know getting that vaccine for the
world uh is is is critical
and you know the world doesn't have a
you know product creation for wh about
standards from marmot green you know so
we're trying to step up and say okay
let's fix this for the entire world
uh individual countries will try and get
the supply allocated to them but only by
having seven billion doses do you really
solve the problem
and we have this question for mile which
bergman on facebook which i think
everyone is wondering about just life
until we have a vaccine and i'll add a
little bit to it which is you know this
world you're describing even in a good
scenario we might be able to normalize
in in places in like the united states
and maybe june but it's not even full
normalization
the vaccine's 18 months away
as we go back into the fall it might
pick back up with the seasonality maybe
what are the economic implications
because you talked about large
gatherings sporting events concerts but
even i can imagine people's behavior
restaurants won't normalize for a very
long time how do you see this playing
out economically
well this will be the
biggest shrinkage of gdp uh
in
any of our lifetimes
and you know there will be businesses
like restaurants or
tourism things that will be dramatically
affected uh
and so yes the opening up uh you know
most jobs and school
uh like in china should be able to
resume
in rich countries that do the right
things
uh by this summer uh you know by then we
ought to have a a
an additional type of testing which is a
lateral flow
rapid diagnostic test that
is very quick we ought to have you know
large numbers of those
uh so that
broadly we don't have to triage quite as
much
in terms of that testing capacity
they
they there will be types of activities
that people will be conservative about
even if the authorities you know if the
model say that those risks are low
uh most people
will it'll take a while to get back into
the
you know let's go take a vacation let's
buy a new house type mode so the economy
uh
will
be
less
vibrant
in lots of sectors and so this idea of
you know how much government help can
there be does that eventually uh cause
uh huge inflation
uh you know we are in unchartered
territory
in terms of how we minimize
that the economy will come back
you know once you get that the vaccine
out there and people
mindset
returns
you know so eventually the economy will
be bigger than it was
uh
before we got into this
uh but
uh
you know the shrinkage we're seeing in
these few months is completely
unprecedented and you know there
are human lives behind that
and there's a ton of questions that have
come through on various social media uh
from uh facebook candy westin burkham uh
facebook greg roman a lot of people are
asking uh kimberly bizac you know why
aren't we having just a really hardcore
shelter in place
nationwide and i'll add
that question maybe make it global
how do people balance i've heard the
argument that the economic harm could
could cause a lot of deaths too and you
could imagine in places like india
you know i've been monitoring some of
the news there of folks who with the
shutdown they have no livelihood and
they don't know how they're going to get
food so that that's going and that's
happening even in the u.s so how do you
weigh those tensions and
what do you see as the dynamics that's
keeping us from a really serious
shutdown versus some of the more scatter
shot things that have been put in place
well whenever you do shutdowns you
always wish you did them a bit earlier
and
you know we should
do this nationwide because we're not
going to partition the country
uh
into separate blocks uh so we you know
we need to get going on that your point
about developing countries is a very
important one because
people live in slums where they're close
to each other
uh
they have to get food every day in rich
countries we'll be able to maintain food
electricity
sewage garbage uh through
you know a several month period there
will be incredible hardships uh but
there won't be you know shortage of food
we shouldn't see civil unrest
coming out of this in the developing
countries you're just not going to
reduce social contacts as much
and
so the likelihood that you can
you know really bend that curve and get
to a small number of cases it may not
may not be possible in developing
countries and so that i'm very worried
about the developing countries
their health capacity is much less the
total number of cases
say in africa or
india today is not gigantic but we are
starting to see it grow
and so
in the end the
it looks likely there'll be more damage
both
in terms of deaths and economic damage
in developing countries than in the rich
countries
and there's a a lot of questions that
have come in on
hopefully
not hope i mean it's a very dystopian
reality that we're finding ourselves in
but what you've articulated is in some
ways a hopeful scenario where we are
able to shut down we are able to surface
in the summer
do you see this flaring back up in the
fall and what do you think just life's
going to be like for the next 18 months
i guess it's just going to be at this
weird new normal
well the next two months hopefully we
you know get that cases down and have
we're so good at that point of quick
turnaround testing contact tracing
testing that we have been and some
ongoing measures like no big public
gathering spacing you know will mask be
part of that we don't know we're trying
to do the experiments to see how much
that reduces transmission uh china is
using that but they're also using
temperature
uh tests we'll see how effective that is
we don't know how seasonal this virus is
if it is seasonal then we'll start to
see the benefit of that and reduce force
of infection in the northern hemisphere
over the next few months sadly that
would mean the southern hemisphere would
be going into the strong season right
now the assumption is that it's not very
seasonal just because that's kind of the
worst case assumption
and these measures can
help us even if it's not seasonal if it
is seasonal as you say yes our vigilance
will have
that might be relaxed a tiny bit in the
summer will have to go back up in the
fall
and a question from greg roman on
facebook how will humanity change as a
result of this
well you know i never lived through
anything this dramatic i you know did
the the depression changed humanity
world war ii changed humanity
uh you know the 2008 recession to some
degree uh changed things this is much
bigger than that 2008 thing you know or
anything that i've ever experienced
and so it's hard to predict i mean
there's you know simple things like will
people take less business trips
uh you know will people you know be
afraid of foreign travel uh
you know i i am concerned will this
drive us together within the country and
across countries to you know solve a
global problem like this or will it have
a say okay you know we just need to uh
hunker down and and just you know
isolate uh at various tribal or national
type levels i see the cooperation of
scientists globally you know enabled by
these digital connections is phenomenal
you know we did the genetics on this
virus very quickly uh that was very
informative that you know testing
understanding in many countries got
going very quickly
uh
you know we are
very much in unchartered territory
and you know so the fact that i saw this
as a risk doesn't mean that i understand
the
uh broad deep effects uh many of which
are uh sadly you know scary and and
potentially negative
yeah and that kind of goes to this
question it's actually a more personal
question from youtube marconetto saying
hello sal and bill as a teen who's
trying to make a difference what are
your tips on maintaining a focused
environment staying productive and
prioritized during this hectic and
uncertain time i i'd love you know i
think a lot of people love to hear you
know how are you coping with the stress
of everyone's trying to say socially
distance but you're trying to to help
the world
well i think it's a great time
uh mostly digitally to you know talk to
your friends understanding the stress
and uncertainty it's causing for them
uh thank god the internet
uh you know looks to have the resilience
uh that it's it's a tool for us to you
know constantly see what's going on have
these collaborations you know the
foundation meetings are always you know
uh virtual so i'm learning about the
rooms that people have in their house
and their cats jumping up on their desk
uh
the
it is a chance you know where you can
learn a lot you know thank goodness uh
that you know the online tools uh khan
academy and uh the lead there there's
amazing materials uh how do you develop
that discipline you know what does your
day look like
uh you know when you're not able to go
out as much uh this is there's some
tough adjustment you know ideally people
would get a rhythm of okay i'm online
doing serious stuff um you know i'm
watching uh you know videos to relax and
entertain myself i'm going these are
some friends that i regularly uh connect
up with digitally
i do think in the next couple of weeks
although they'll be immense tension will
fall into a pattern and there's no
reason that learning at least for those
who have access shouldn't go on or you
know even to some degree intensify the
fact that some students don't have
access even here in the united states
and some districts are therefore saying
you know maybe they shouldn't do
anything
that is going to create disparities
that
you know you and i have talked about in
the fall how do we help
get students who've lost the entire
three months
you know how do we encourage them
uh and really uh
allow them
uh to regain that material i mean losing
three months of learning
uh
you know there's a huge cost to that
it's hard to put a dollar number on it
but you know uh no matter what grade
you're in
uh
you know it's it's
it's very uh you know it's a it's a huge
setback
yeah
and one last question maybe i'll throw
in too you know there's we talked about
a likely scenario uh i'm almost afraid
to think about a a worst-case scenario
uh you know there's possibilities i mean
i am curious do you think we might have
shutdowns again in the fall type of
scenario but also i i'd love to finish
up on are is there silver lining to this
is there something that you you're
hopeful of that that might come out of
it you know some people say you should
never waste a good crisis
how are you thinking about that
well part of the reason our foundation
has been funding
these new diagnostic tools and vaccine
platforms is that they're useful
not just for the pandemic threat
but also for
diseases like tuberculosis hiv malaria
that we've got and so you know we've
been funding these things for over a
decade uh and they do look promising
both for coronavirus and those other
things i will say that uh
you know the the thing that we didn't
act on
uh
you know five years ago when the the
danger was clear this time
uh governments will act on it we will
uh get the right tools in place and it's
the resources of society are
dramatically dramatically less than we
spend say on the the military to be
prepared prepared for that eventuality
uh you know hopefully some families are
drawn closer together the idea of you
know volunteering to help out people
uh giving philanthropically
um
you know we were all in this together
uh even on a a global basis and so
uh this
you know the rest of your life you will
think of this event how you responded to
it uh as a
you know defining
thing and you know i'm i'm seeing many
people rise to the occasion to help out
others
uh or to use their skills to try and
bring this to an end
oh thank you so much we could obviously
talk for hours i'm sure many people
would love to hear there's we could tell
there's just so much more that we could
learn especially about the virus but
thank you so much bill for joining us
this was a real treat
yeah great to talk to you saul
thanks
thank you
so thank you everyone for joining uh
this live stream uh i think we all
learned a lot today uh i hope that we
can have a future live streams where we
can as i've talked about in previous
versions you know talk about whether
it's the pandemic uh talking about how
do we
keep learning how do we deal with kids
at home who might have trouble staying
focused uh but regardless thanks for
joining as bill just mentioned the
silver lining behind all of this is that
this is a bit of a shared experience for
all of humanity and uh as stressful as
it is the more that we can stay
connected i think the more it'll help
all of us get through this so i will see
you on monday
you